is donald trump actually instituting
the martial law that we were warned
barack obama was actually going to
institute if you were paying attention
to politics during the barack obama
administration
you might remember the unhinged
belligerent
fearmongering from the right that barack
obama plans to enact martial law in the
united states
some versions of the conspiracy said
that it was part of a plan to enslave
people in fema camps
sometimes rfid chips were involved
sometimes not uh
and all of this was part of obama's
bigger plan to suspend the 2012 election
which he didn't do
and then it was actually about
suspending the 2016 election and
remaining in power indefinitely while
bringing authoritarian militaristic
terror to the streets of america
against the wishes of state and local
authorities and elected officials
and if you were paying attention you
knew that barack obama
had no interest in doing any such thing
there was no chance whatsoever
that that was what barack obama was
going to do but that gets us to today
and we actually have to have a
discussion today
about whether donald trump is indeed
instituting martial law
by the forceful deployment of
paramilitaries to cities around the
country
where if you look at portland for
example those troops have
tear-gassed the mayor of portland more
on that later
attacked reporters and journalists and
so the first
step is what is martial law if we don't
know what it is it's hard to determine
whether we are seeing it well martial
law is when normal
civil functions and civil law are
replaced by military control
sometimes martial law can be declared
during a real
or fabricated emergency situation as a
lead up to
or after a coup in the context of a
natural disaster or states of emergency
and there's some other situations as
well
and often martial law includes any or
all of the following
the military in the streets working as
local law enforcement
curfews the suspension of habeas corpus
and
normal due process military law and
justice being applied
to civilians so do we have
literal martial law today in the united
states no
we don't uh is what donald trump has
done so far
literal fascism it's not but we're
seeing what the
early phases of potentially future
widespread martial law could look like
if slowly deployed now if you deny this
basic fact
you're denying reality right now it's
not all happening at once
it's not completely obvious unless you
look step by step
but that's what makes it harder to see
and in fact authoritarian dictators
understand this and they often deploy
martial law
in baby steps now again to be completely
clear
i am not saying we will soon have a
fully authoritarian police state martial
law situation in the united states
and part of the reason we may not is
trump will run out of time he will
either
win reelection and no longer need these
authoritarian escalations to try to help
himself get reelected
or he will lose and as far as i'm
concerned he will leave
office and thus it will stop the
escalation as well
but think through the steps donald trump
is deploying
federal troops armed paramilitaries to
cities and towns
these troops aren't part of the normal
military branches they're part of
homeland security but they really are a
military that is
functioning at the pleasure of the
president as local law enforcement
overriding local law enforcement
camouflaged with body armor carrying
heavy weapons
throwing people into unmarked vans even
local politicians and reporters are
getting hit
now many of them are being released
after being thrown
into a van and brought to who knows
where
and it's true that when you look at some
of the worst police states and martial
law situations of the last
40 50 years around the world many of
them don't release people without
charges if it turns out they don't want
to charge you
sometimes they bring you into a dark
room and they kill you and you never
hear from them again you never hear
you are never heard from again and this
happened to friends of my parents
in the 1970s during the military
dictatorship in argentina
that's not where we are and we're not
actually close to that right now
but at least colloquially they are
replacing
civil law with troops federal troops
quite literally if mayors and governors
don't want them there
they are in conflict with local law
enforcement
they are enforcing a sort of federal
military law and putting it above
supreme to local law enforcement
now the typical justification is being
given this also
fits with history which is that it's an
emergency
now this gets us into interesting
territory
the incredible thing is that we have
real emergencies right now
we have an emergency which is the
pandemic and the mishandling of the
pandemic by the federal government
meaning the trump administration
we have another emergency which is the
economic crisis happening
which is far worse than it had to be as
a result of donald trump's mishandling
of the pandemic
but that's not the emergency that donald
trump is actually pointing to
to justify these troops in portland and
chicago and other places soon
trump is saying the emergency is out of
control
cancel culture protesters destroying
statues
and federal property and trying to burn
courthouses to the ground
that's not the real emergency in fact
that's not even actually happening as
described
the emergency is a thousand or more
people per day again
dying of coronavirus 11 unemployment
the pending eviction crisis cuts to the
uh
unemployment insurance benefits and the
like that's the emergency but that's not
why trump says he's sending in the
troops
so now they start bolstering this
environment of fear and panic
as a result of the federal troops being
there and people are starting to wonder
how long are we going to live like this
are we going to be able to vote
normally in november are these troops
going to be
intimidating me at the voting booth in
november by
patrolling with heavy uh uh weapons
and this is quite literally the way it's
done this is out of the playbook
playbook slowly creeping in
to where we start thinking well it's
normal to have the armed
paramilitaries in cities across the
country
but this next thing isn't yet normal but
then you get the next thing and okay now
that's normal
but the next thing isn't yet normal it's
the slow normalization
now there they have the benefit that
there are some people
already on the side of the
paramilitaries that's another issue and
we'll talk about that probably not today
but maybe later in the week
so if you're waiting for one day at
which
we confirm today at 12 15 p.m
we have now reached martial law or
something like that
by design that's not how it happens it
started with years ago trump joking
about
maybe i'll stay in power i like the idea
of how china now allows the president to
be re-elected indefinitely
uh trump attacking the free press
kicking out you know early on i think it
was jim acosta from the white house
uh briefings momentarily and you know it
starts with that attacks on the press
etc
that became normalized trump attacks the
press all the time now
barely gets attention well then now
there's troops in portland and soon in
chicago and other cities next and some
people are already fine with it because
they believe donald trump's explanation
for why
we need the troops to be there in the
first place and then before you know it
we have a national emergency with
paramilitaries deployed
nationwide regularly repressing
not just peaceful protesters with
flowers and signs but even attacking
journalists and members of the press
covering what's going on which we are
already seeing and could potentially
increase
and then you've got trump's federal
troops on election day
presiding over an election in which
trump himself
is trying to get himself re-elected if
you thought
secretary of state brian kemp in florida
running the election in which he was a
candidate for governor was bad
then think about trump deploying
paramilitaries
to supervise his own reelection
campaign this is how it creeps in and i
hope people are starting
to see it and realizing how important it
is to put a stop to this
and you know put a stop to it we may not
be able to stop
the deployment of the troops but by not
taking our eye off the ball which is
this is a desperate cornered president
who sees the polls and knows as of today
that he's losing
and he could be embarrassed in a
historic electoral college route by joe
biden if things don't change right
that's the whole point
he is now extremely desperate and that's
very dangerous
and so we need to make sure that at the
top level
this is not allowed to change the
character of the november election
in five weeks there are certain states
that can start early voting absentee
do it every single week do not be
dissuaded keep your eye on the ball
because we've only got three months to
go
we know the plan we know the slow
creeping
of authoritarianism we're seeing it
right now
we've been hearing about it from people
like timothy snyder and others for a
long time this is this is it this is no
longer rehearsal we've got three months
and this is the game plan and we're
starting to see the signs we're going to
continue
covering this on the david pakman show
instagram
page which i invite you to follow at
davidpakmanshow
while you're there follow me on
instagram at david.pakman for a break
from the authoritarianism
non-politics uh non-political stuff
on my instagram page we'll take a quick
break i do want to talk about the latest
senate predictions
and so much happened over the weekend to
catch you up on